yes I'll open quickly the reconvened
work session
we do have a budget from the legislative
branch and
you want to speak to it or hand it out
well I
I don't have copies and I am I asked
Aaron uh whether they were it was
exactly what was in the budget book I
think it's not exactly the same but it
um so we can if you guys want it surely
we can make copies of it I wouldn't want
you to fly blind on this but um there
really weren't many changes from 2023
from the last biennium at all it's a
flat budget they actually had a decrease
in cost for um
for benefits which the chairman Weiler
remarked on and they were saying that
they were doing um a really great job we
did have a a bit of a discussion about
the uh technology budget there were
um and just to let you know they have
three more media people and that's to
really work on the live stream issues
that are really really popular
with members with the public with just
about everybody things are archived
pretty much on YouTube but what uh Terry
puff said was they are doing some other
archiving so we're not entirely
relying on um on YouTube so they did
have an increase in uh Personnel but
they decreased the consultant line so in
the end it's a it's a flat budget and it
was
unanimously
approved so the bottom line for the
whole thing I mean look is the same as
it always is I guess it's uh
about 21 million dollars
and then the the only other thing I
would add
um was that I did report to them on the
division's activities
um and I we talked about
um HB 384.
what about your request to put the money
in from the legislative account for the
parking garage so
and what uh Terry
said was that he explained to the to the
Joint facilities committee that for that
2.5 million to be used they did have to
approve it and they did have to
um
they did have to decide how to divvy up
the the 2.5 million dollars because
there's several accounts within the
legislative account the house the Senate
the LBA and there's one other thing that
I'm not
thinking of but they didn't vote on that
because the bill hasn't been passed yet
but overall they weren't opposed to no
no not at all no nobody had a comment on
that the only other thing that came up
was that uh Terry
did mention that when they were I talked
about the joint legislative parking
garage oversight commission and the only
thing that Terry mentioned was that they
might want to consider on the Senate
side adding somebody from the city of
Concord
and there were no questions on it I mean
and
that was they were pleased to hear yeah
they were pleased to hear that it went
through on a Voice vote
and the other thing I told them was that
in hb2 was the granite Place
acquisition that the governor had put in
21 million for
all right so I guess we can accept the
legislative Branch's budget just show a
hands everybody okay with that
all right Melissa we're
our last big check off
I I misstate it it's I'm sorry I'm kind
of tired it's 20 million a year right
yes I said for the I meant I said for
the biennium it's per year 21 though but
it's flat so that's why we were so quick
to approve it it's such a reduction
anyway
all right go ahead representative
McGuire I think each drafter in OLS
makes more money than the entire
legislature put together
[Laughter]
all right um
Mr Hoffman just handed out a breakdown
of House Bill 2 this is
updated complete so everybody has a a
final draft so all the others that you
have floating around in your pile you
can toss if you want but so um
this is for your information Deanne and
I will be working off of this on Monday
when we present our changes and
to the full committee this and the
things we did in uh house bill one
representative McGuire does have a
number at least two or three amendments
right yeah would you like to speak to
them sure why don't we start with this
well I don't know if this one's ready
the agriculture one
not really okay we'll wait on that one
so
um
House Bill 436
um is is now an amendment and it and the
one we passed was Amendment 1187 H but
I'd like to propose that we replace it
with Amendment 1191 h
so 1191 H the only difference is we
start paying for this you know if you
remember this is 25 million dollars a
year for a 10-year period but in the
original the 10-year period started
fiscal year 25.
and this amendment it starts fiscal year
24. so
um
in a sense I I don't feel comfortable
asking future bienniums to do more than
we're willing to do in our current
biennium and I spoke to the other
division chairs about this and and the
chair of the finance committee they're
all on board with it
um when I mentioned at the
representative Edwards
that
um you know I said exactly that that we
want to do in this biennium what we're
asking future bienniums to do and he
said yeah that's leadership so
so so I I I would feel more comfortable
doing this and we do have the money
um obviously it makes the bottom line a
little bit narrower but I think it's the
right thing to do
yeah representative McGuire and I spoke
about this yesterday it sounded like a
pretty good idea to me
uh well we have updated sheets from
Monday obviously for this change by
backing it backwards the 25 million
um
Mike can probably update this for Monday
but he will have the full Surplus state
statement after all the division
activity
Monday Tuesday Wednesday
and on this document House Bill 2 what
we usually provide is
a list of the amended sections with the
Amendments so the things that say
accepted accepted accepted
you won't see because the discussion
will just be on what did division one
as we've done in the past each agency
whether there's a change in those
add-ons if I remember the eight and a
half by 14 sheet of paper is that close
to available now you have one of those
available
I'll be able to
um finish it up this afternoon for you
to rehearse rehearse over the weekend
for your presentation you get that to
the entire division certainly to
representative McGuire and myself that
would be great yeah we just have to
clean it up a little it's ready to go no
problem so are we all okay with their
their suggested change getting back to
1191 representative McGuire's change
just show a quick hands
yeah we'll do that very official
it's been moved and seconded
Okay so
it was a show of hands
six zero
you have another one or
yeah
the 270s
thing
um yeah so we also have here Amendment
1197 H to house bill 276. so this really
isn't the house bill too should we do
you want to do just House Bill 2 for the
moment or oh we got so little to do we
can jump around okay so
um if if you recall uh house bill
I'm sorry turn off if you recall House
Bill 276 that was the cyanobacteria
mitigation loan and Grant fund and
originally it had very problematic
funding because it was going to borrow
25 million and then give some out as
loans and some as grants and so on so we
had we had retained it
um and I believe the in the full
committee we've we've also retained it
but I want to sort of reconsider this
because I was approached by the prime
sponsor representative run yesterday and
she said said to me we want to make
changes with this in the Senate couldn't
you just take out all the money and then
pass it and I said sure why not so
yeah so that's what we're doing so that
this amendment 1197
um it just it just puts a dollar in the
fund and but but all the beginning
sections that create the fund and the
purpose and the rules and that sort of
stuff are still there but there's no
money here so
and so I recommend that we pass this and
um just sent keep it as a bill and and
let her
push it into the Senate um
Etc
representative evil
um I support this very enthusiastically
uh for in addition to removing the money
for obvious reasons but in particular if
we were responsible for reviewing it
upon the retain it really would involve
us analyzing
cyanobacteria plume issues within a
finance division which I don't really
think is our purview and this way if it
passes through the house which I'm
hoping that it does it will go to the
Senate policy committee and they can dig
in a little bit more than we'd really be
able to so I support this
so Amendment 1197 has been moved and
seconded by representative Ebola II and
moved by representative McGuire are
there further questions any
questions anyone
oh there you go
very good so we'll just have a simple
show of hands in it make it easier six
zero Madame Clark
you have another one representative
McGuire well I think there's one for
house bill 50 right
yeah thanks Mike
thank you sir
do you sleep representative
last few days not too well no
um what are you gonna do with all your
spare time after next week I'm going to
play more Bridge
foreign
Amendment 1075 H so if you as you may
remember from Wednesday very
gratifyingly the house uh strongly
passed this idea for the amendment to
house bill 50 and put it on the table so
that we could now adopt this amendment
uh to House Bill 2 and put the policy
into house bill too it's the one that
pays down the unfunded liability 50
million dollars right away essentially
right away at the at the from money in
the current biennium not money in the
next biennial
is it seconded representative camberells
comments from the division
uh seeing none I will add there was a
little confusion as you may recall on
the floor with the tabling motion this
is something that we don't often do but
we have done like the revenues we accept
the revenues and we put them on the
table I did have a good discussion with
representative O'Brien to assure him
there was no scandalous activity in play
here the Senate does it all the time
so the bills don't come over to us a
week yeah yeah
so we don't kill their bills during a
budget year so I thought it was great
strategy representative McGuire thank
you for the amendment those in favor of
moving forward with this hands please
6-0 thank you I don't have to worry
about being lynched you almost have
thrown out the window last night
[Laughter]
is that it representative McGuire um
well there's this agricultural thing
yeah so if you either one of us you
would like to speak to it yeah so
apparently
um we heard from
um commissioner Jasper of the of the uh
the agriculture commissioner and there's
a section of House Bill 2 which is
um it's at the top of page six of this
new index section 267.
and
um
he asked us to just simply remove this
section uh it's it's not a there's no
money in it this is simply a um
a section to change how often this
particular board meets and some
characteristics of their meetings and in
current law they meet
twice a year and one of the meetings is
designated to be for public input it's a
public hearing
the the this section makes them meet
four times a year
and they would really have to take
public input at every meeting
okay and so
um so he wants us to Simply remove the
section I spoke to
Howard Pearl Senator Pearl about this
he's the last year he was the chair of
our environment and AG committee he also
has a bill actually the Senate bill this
year about this board not about this
subject though his his bill is changing
the membership of the board some details
about that because apparently they're
having trouble
finding enough members of the right
types and it's one of these things where
there's it's a big board and you know
you got to have one from this County and
one from that County and you know one of
these and one of those and so his bill
is kind of just saying to the governor
pick enough people you know because
they're having trouble finding people
anyway
so
my we could go two ways on this right we
could we could just take out the section
um I kind of like the public input part
of it you know just having public input
once a year why not if they're having
two meetings have public input at both
meetings right so I asked them to make
an amendment that took out the the four
times a year meeting but left the public
input and I guess we don't have it ready
yet but that's what it is
and any discussion
seeing none I I did speak to the
commissioner as well and Apparently one
of the get-togethers is they discuss who
the next commissioner should be which
seems like kind of a wasted time if the
commission's appointed for four years
anyway so once we get that we'll we're
okay with that representative McGuire so
it's
moved by representative McGuire and
seconded by representative Hewitt
and just a quick show of hands please
six to zero Madam Clerk
Melissa Mike anything else uh
that we have to do to close the envelope
uh yep I think there's an amendment or
there should be an amendment in front of
you uh 2023 1184 H oh yeah you just
meant you gave that to us
this amendment is a representative
Weiler amendment that came from
representative Eaton who's on the public
works and Highway committee
I believe they want a division one to
take it up so it can be ready for full
committee on Monday they just gave it to
us this morning it's
1184 1184.
representative evil you were on public
works you comment on this or just like
gazing upon it here so I haven't seen it
anymore
yeah can I just look for something oh
sure sure
essentially it's supposed to be
Expediting the short-term rental
equipment contracts
by changing the definition of projects
foreign
yeah I I'm fine with this I was
particularly interested because you'll
recall that we changed the name of the
capital budget overview committee to the
capital project overview committee so
this is where the definition of project
resides
um but this doesn't affect any of that
so I think it's fine
any other further comments
Professor McGuire yeah
it seems I'm I'm happy to vote for it it
just seems somewhat in Artful
construction to put active law in a
definition in the way that this sort of
does
someone like to move
it's adoption
awesome representative grassy's second
second by representative Hewitt
you're all in favor just to show a hands
please
uh six to zero
I agree with you professor
you don't usually look in definitions to
see what happens you know they can it's
they can clean it up over here
but I saw this I'm like whoa
so Mr Hoffman Melissa is that pretty
much it for us
and again I um it's I want to thank you
to for your efforts it's been amazing I
know Melissa this is your first time on
this side of the
street so to speak and uh
you've done very very very very well
and uh Mr Hoffman as always a great team
people have asked us why we have two LBA
folks I've told them is because we're
not as bright as the other divisions but
but no we the work we've had I think
probably Mike can speak to this and if
Jerry was here I don't think I've ever
seen so much activity in division one
we're usually the quiet just the nuts
and bolts of keeping state government
going but with the oplc the retirement
the tunnel
yeah that's how we started yeah how we
started so it's been but we we got to a
good place and again as I thank the
members
both day was that Tuesday
we did a lot of good work there was
great compromise and again Mike and
Melissa without your help we'd probably
still be uh weeks out
so thanks again we'll see you on Monday
thank you
no
any I I just want to thank them both too
you're the backbone of what we've done
and I just don't know how we could have
gotten through it all and I also want to
thank the chairman who really kept the
Train on the tracks we had a lot going
on so
um thanks to everybody it's my first
time here I really
enjoyed it in quotes
and thanks to you representative McGuire
you did a heck of a lot of work
especially on the oplc stuff and the
retirement system I don't know how we'd
have gotten through all of that I did
want to ask the chairman what's next for
us newbies
so representative McGuire and I will
present our work to the full committee
on Monday and we'll have Melissa and
Mike sitting directly behind us should
we mess up
and we'll go over everything that we
took out and we added so all the
differences between the governor's
budget and our recommendations the full
committee so then the full committee
will vote I believe that's how the chair
has that's how we've done it in the past
the full committee will vote on our
recommendation then we'll go to division
two they'll make their presentation a
full committee will vote on theirs and
we'll go to three and then the full
committee will vote on the entire
package
and that probably won't be until Tuesday
but depends how quickly we go in
division one or two and three progress
uh Mr Kane will have a breakdown of
where we stand financially the Surplus
statement what's going the rainy day
fund and we're very good I think you've
seen the numbers we're in a really good
place all the divisions and getting a
balanced budget to the Senate hopefully
what our work will you know pass on the
house floor there'll be a lot of debate
in the next couple weeks
we'll be in our division
that in something that has gone kind of
under the radar and I was speaking to
someone about it this morning that's the
employee pay raise it came through here
you know we had a complete review by the
department of administrative Services a
complete breakdown by departments and
agencies that's a significant that's a
hundred million dollars here to give all
our state employees a 10 pay raise and
that's what we'll be presenting that's I
think a very positive thing and because
it wasn't as controversial as like some
of the others but that's a significant
piece of this budget to you know give
our employees a significant deserved pay
raise so
so it's true that we couldn't do
anything about it anyway we could have
rejected it yeah yeah we could have said
no
um we couldn't afford it
even though the governor negotiated
again in good faith if we didn't fund it
um but I think we made the right
decision and yeah so yeah
for example in my town we rejected the
school uh the collective bargaining
agreement just recently so they have to
go back to the table right all we get to
do is say yes or no we don't get to say
you know five percent less or something
yeah he's in representing McGuire's
right it's either yes or no we well
maybe if we could have done five well
that was negotiated so it's up or down
oh it's this uh
cultural wow they're really turning
stuff around quickly
thanks Mike
so do you have to go to Festival well we
have pre-fiscal but we don't have much
of a it's not a bad day
a compared to all of this
we're also exacting a whole bunch of
bills I guess on Tuesday so if we don't
get through everything might it go to
Wednesday or is that I don't know what
our deadline is yeah we do I mean we
could certainly talk about I think we
have four bills that are coming out of
here
oh it did okay yeah I think we're we're
meeting all three days but if we're
quick maybe
so I don't know that's far more
important
[Music]
yeah so uh
yeah
yeah so the list I have it is Tuesday
for exec the 28th yes
um I have not gone through and checked
out I think looking at the sheet
yesterday that we only have four
in most of those were
being moved to the um
House Bill too so
we don't have the workload we had
earlier with the 17th
sometimes
yeah
so there's 250.
36 571 it's all probably yours
yes and I think there was one other but
I
Janet's working on the list right now as
far as the speakers and
we'll we'll have that out represent
camera I saw the Janet sent out a
calendar and it showed at one o'clock
today fiscal means what could you tell
me a little bit about that what that is
because I've not encountered that before
no and not a problem so the fiscal
committee consists of five house members
and five senate members
and uh
the chair of the fiscal committee is a
chair of finance and the vice chair is
the chair of Senate Finance
in essentially I I'm one of the members
on fiscal generally it's the division
shares not always because I was on
fiscal last term even though I was not a
division chair but it's all up to the
speaker and the uh
the Senate appoints there the Senate
President appoints who he wants or she
wants and the same with the
representative Weiler he appoints to
and then the speaker appoints to so
that's why sometimes you'll have like a
bipartisan makeup like the Democrats may
suggest somebody and the speaker can
make that decision
and essentially what we do is we look at
all the federal money not all of it but
most of it that comes into the state
whether we should approve the acceptance
of that money whether they're strings a
tide commitments if we take it and it's
not all free sometimes you have to
provide matches or continue the programs
um if a an agency needs a more money to
function like say Corrections doesn't
have enough in overtime we can move
money from another area of government or
within their budget to support over time
or the judicial Council I see someone
that follows that closely they often run
out of money and have to come to fiscal
and make a request to
seek additional funds so so that's good
that's great thank you for the uh and I
can see where that would be critical to
in case agencies were sure or needed
something but in regard to the federal
funds I thought the executive Council
typically decides if we accept federal
funds for the state there's a lot that
go through both
so they may approve something that has
to come to us or something comes to us
it has to go to them
so there's actually kind of some
crossover am I missing anything Mike or
Melissa
no you covered it pretty well
um regarding uh governing Council
smaller stuff we'll go to them fiscal
committee's threshold I think is a
hundred thousand dollars so Governor
Council approve smaller things then once
gets a hundred thousand they both have
to prove it
um the way I usually explain it is this
is our best guess for what's going to
happen over the next two years starting
July 1st but it's only a guess it's a
point in time and when things change as
they will right the fiscal committee is
is
um allowed to make in-course Corrections
right revenues aren't hitting the thing
they got to do something extra extra
things happen they got to do something
so that's that's what happens
one last show in in that regard do they
they still have to go back to the Full
House and Senate for approval or they
have the power that's the problem
and that's why I
I've always pushed very strong for the
house to pass a budget
because say we don't pass a budget then
there's uh
continuing resolutions to keep the state
going and the fiscal committee makes
that decision that's right so there's an
awful lot of power there are a number of
people and myself representative Smith
chaired the fiscal committee Marjorie
Smith for several terms and I share her
concern that's an awful lot of power to
be placed in just 10 individuals so we
meet year-round
all year round we and there are requests
dozens of requests we have today today
isn't too much of a huge event but we
took in
like 1.6 billion dollars in federal
funds in the last year that came through
fiscal
and most of the requests are granted is
a lot of debate I have to say the
members on both sides are very thorough
no matter what parties very nonpartisan
group you'll see like
um
representative Edwards and I have been
hard on a couple things that have come
in jointly um
and work together so it's very
non-partisan but
again I think the legislature and the
Senate should be making a lot of the
decisions that we often make
so let's see oh yeah representative evil
had a question on
Amendment 11 19 that was dealing with
invest
I thought we did approve that
the reductions wasn't that Joseph
I think she got scared because my name
is
I just see two pieces of paper here one
never went into my folder so that means
yeah I believe we did yep we passed it
out on Tuesday and voted on Tuesday
thanks Melissa you're welcome sorry
so you have anything for us uh
just trying to keep
all right
all right well we'll see you uh all on
Monday at 10 A.M
again thanks guys
that's it so I like that the professor